for Learning and about how we can use
transfer learning to explore uh neural
language models and language threat
structure and yeah of course a lot of
those records is done with or all this
work it is my advisor Dan uh draft Steve
was here and yeah I'm going to talk a
bit about transfer learning as a
methodology a bit about structure and
language and like why why it's like
important in human language and maybe
what
um insights that kind of thinking can
have for non-human communication and uh
yeah and then I'm going to get into our
experiments these kind of analysis
experiments cool so uh what is transfer
learning as a methodology right if
you've uh if you're in machine learning
this is very clear but if you're not may
maybe it's not right it's when we have
an untrained model right and then we
have one type of data which is a it's
usually like data that we would have a
lot of somehow right so in the case of
NLP it's often
um like just language modeling data in
English right so we could just scrape
the internet when we could just predict
the next word on that right and then
um and then uh you and so and so you
train this with some training of the
predict Max word type or something
similar and then you have a second type
of data right which is
um which is more specialized you maybe
have less of and and there's some
similarities be between these two types
of data that you may notice and that may
be interesting they may be like very
latent types of similarities and like
types of structure or uh or you know if
it's like two very different languages
they're still both languages right and
and so in noticing these similarities
you can decide to take the the already
trained model from from data one and
then train that on your second data set
right and and that's what trend transfer
learning is this idea that we can
transfer Knowledge from one data set to
another
um uh and especially when there's kind
of like data imbalance right when we
have a lot of one type but not so much
of something else
and you know Trends learning has many
practical applications right for example
um Trend uh in in the NLP space right we
can like take an English model and adapt
it to another language right there's
like maybe 7 000 languages in the world
and like maybe only three in which we
can train like a gpd4 size model right
and uh from scratch uh maybe the three
number
is not fully correct but it's somewhere
there right and um
and and what I'm going to talk about
here is not so much this practical side
of transfer learning but also how it's
an analysis methodology for
understanding how data and learning uh
works and
um and and essentially I I I would like
to focus on on this idea and kind of
this moment where we're at now where
like powerful machine learning models
they let us explore questions about
language uh in new ways and and uh and
in our case we can use transfer learning
between different types of data to kind
of understand
um things about language itself and what
kind of things can get transferred uh in
machine learning and thinking about
language as a learnable system in in the
abstract
uh and and you know for for an example
of like the kinds of structures that can
be uh transferred between uh between
different types of data you know even
when there isn't a shared modality uh we
can have you know we we we might want to
transfer to English right and this is
more like for the analysis case right
you often want to just transfer to the
language in order to find out what kinds
of structures Aid language learning and
then we could start from either random
numbers or we can start from from midi
data right from music data and uh and
what we see is that it's actually much
much better to start from music data
right so so if we pre pre-train on um on
music data we we get this huge drop
right the the this is this is just like
a catchy example of the types of
experiments so we will be doing but uh
rather than like be an analytical core
but uh yeah I think it's really cool
right that that gives all these ways in
which music and language really writes
through ways in which like different
parts of of an utterance are or are are
are related and in this complex kind of
like macro structures and um and and you
and you can see this play out in machine
learning models
uh and so what we're doing
um here is using transfer learning as a
testbed for for linguistic structure
hypotheses right so if instead of Music
we uh we pick some uh some some
structure that we think is like
significant for for language and we make
a little like synthetic data set or a
big synthetic data set out of that right
and we see how well this transfers to
English you know we could do this with
another hypothesis and another
hypothesis I'm going to go like in much
more detail into what these hypotheses
can be later but uh this what this gives
us is an ability to kind of test out the
kinds of structures which which exist in
in language or in any form of second you
know or in any form of data that we have
here right which which could could be
you know of course kind of structured
communication that we're interested in
of any species right and and it lets us
kind of understand which which of these
hypotheses kind of form a good
structural inductive bias for language
without and all this is while being kind
of outside the domain kind of of
theoretical Linguistics which is like
very
um you know there's like a long history
it's very hard to kind of come up with
these ideas uh much harder than just
like generating some some data and
training a model on it
and and and so and so what we and so uh
were so and so what we're doing with
experiments like this is that we use the
structural transfer learning uh to
explore the role of structure and
language learning and in language in
general
so where's um so where's uh you know NLP
now like how does this fit into like
the gpt4 or or
whatever and I thought it might be
useful to go for this stuff of course I
have one in NLP knows us all very well
but in recent NLP there's kind of a
strange type almost of transfer where
you just where you pre-trained so much
with so much data that then if you have
some tasks you want to do uh you can
just describe it in language right and
so then you're not actually you're not
actually really doing any further
transfer learning right this is what's
called prompting and it's what you kind
of contend with when you open up like
chat GPT right it's uh and so then like
where does transfer learning fit in in
in in in in this picture it's uh mostly
for when we want to look Beyond right
the few dominant languages that that we
can get this prom prompting behavior in
right when we're interested in uh in
Sharing like the the basic linguistic
structure Beyond like you know languages
that are dominated the internet and we
just have unlimited data and essentially
two languages that don't or modalities
that don't in the same way where we
cannot get the same amount of data and
as I've said before for for these kind
of analysis experiments
so these analysis experiments we've
um you know we've I'm clearly very
interested in structure in language
right this is like maybe a given for for
many linguists or anyone who's thought
about language but thought it would be
useful to uh go into structure and
language kind of in a more abstract way
and to think about you know maybe where
this is or isn't relevant right for
people in this Workshop
um
and you know
structure you know in in some form is
pretty characteristic of human language
right so uh you know I
um we we say a lot of utterances and
they're all very unique right and
they're all very different but in some
sense there there are ways in which they
all follow similar structural ideas
right so so things like you know I could
say something like I ate a sandwich or
something like I washed my car and those
sentences are very different but but
they both kind of share right the same
kind of like sub-subject verb object
structure beneath them right and so
and and structure is most obviously
present in syntax right so and and I'll
talk in more detail about some of these
features but syntax
very clearly kind of orders language
it's like us a set of rules but it's
also present very much like Beyond
syntax right starting of course from
like the phonological
system and how sounds work and going to
you know the way that meaning structures
our language right so if we're if we
speak some words we're gonna you know
we're gonna be seeing things that make
sense to say it along those words right
and Valence and a topic if we you know
if if we're kind of in a discourse right
if I say something like however this
kind of structure is both what I said
before and what I said after and
connects them right in terms of
reference so if I'm just talking about
the the same person I could use pronouns
I could use a title I could use their
name right and those are all kind of
structuring the discourses referring to
a person information structure right so
what's new and what's old and and how
and how that that kind of um
uh influences how we bring it up
um is is
um very important and so kind of
thinking of structure in this like very
broad way we want to think what
structural biases are sufficient for
language learning right so if we have a
learner that that's kind of ingested a
lot of some types of structure what what
make it a good and sufficient uh learner
for uh learning language from too much
data
and then go beyond like the the scope of
this talk but I still think it's very
interesting like to bring up when
talking about structure and language
because it's often overlooked and uh I
think it is very relevant to uh thinking
about communication General right is
that
structure you know you might think that
it might come from you know some people
might think it might just be handed from
nowhere certain parts of the way that
our language are structured or just like
in the brain by default or something but
there there is certainly also a lot of
ways in which
communication and communicative intent
and uh and language use right so so what
we tend to do in the patterns we form
kind of create historically and in and
um synchronously uh create uh the
grammars and structures that we uh use
so
if you remember before when I talked
about linguistic hypothesis one two and
three uh we're we're gonna kind of look
at three three three important features
of language or things that have been you
know talked a lot as being important and
uh try to disentangle them through this
kind of transfer learning
experimentation uh so first we can look
at recursion right this is like
um very basic uh very um you know in in
sort of
conceptualizing you know the modern
field of linguistics like a 80-ish you
know 70-ish years ago in house form kind
of the idea of recursion that language
can be recursive was like an extremely
prominent idea and continues to be and
what we're thinking of recursion is that
there's constituents in language that um
that kind of work as as a whole and then
can be kind of slotted into other
constituents of the same type or can be
kind of slaughtered around and you can
create these pre-structured
uh structures right so if we have a
sentence right like the cat sat on the
mat that's um that that that's a
sentence right it's a full utterance and
um and and so we can take it and Slot it
into uh a bigger sentence that that
takes a sentence in it right so like
it's like I think that the cat sat on
the mat right now we have another
sentence right that and we could also
slot that into any sentence which
um accepts a sentence as as long as it
makes sense right so it's something you
always accuse me that I think that the
cat sat on the mat right and we can
continue doing this as long as we seem
like not totally mad
um
and
another kind of more uh
uh
and another way in which Rick recursion
has been expressed in in language or
shown right is this idea of of nesting
constituents right and so we have
nesting constituents that means that
you're almost certainly not just tacking
them on at the end and you do have some
kind of recursive
process right so so so there's many
um uh yeah there's many structures that
appear in language that you can't either
you that you can't uh produce by a
process where you're like oh I'm gonna
do this now and I'm gonna do this now
I'm gonna do this and you've clearly
like done one thing and then put
something inside the other uh so this is
you know context video for talking in
the formal language uh sense I'm not
going to go too much into the formal
language uh
um aspect of this of this talk to
formally but yeah if you wanna I'm very
happy to answer questions but yeah right
and this is like a sentence like like
this right we have a noun phrase we have
the dog right and then we have another
noun phrase we have like the man that
that the dog bit right so then that's
itself now and then we have another noun
phrase where we just slot that old one
inside we have the lawyer that the man
that that the dog a bit hired right and
so this
again this kind of Center nesting stuff
it's kind of hard to process right so
you you you you you you can technically
do that infinitely where if you have one
and you add another one you'd be like
you can kind of do that but then it's
also you know you it's also hard to
process if it becomes too too too deep
but there doesn't seem to be this
ability for like arbitrary nesting in
this Center Way
um
and then uh another thing which is
clearly present in language co-occurring
with with these like recursive
constituent structures is this idea of
Crossing links and and dependency right
so so there's linking um in meaning of
course right as I said before if you use
a word there's like all these ways in
which it influences all the words around
it and like How likely they are to
appear later right and and in reference
right so if we have
um if we have a sentence here in which
there are uh two people right there's
like a voter and a politician right we
have like I voted for him even though
I'm negatively affected by his
distribution policies he said right so
we have we we have these like links of
reference between the voter and the
politician which um
uh sorry between the same agents right
which which don't abide by recursive
principles and I really don't don't have
to right they're not part of this kind
of like uh context-free syntax idea
and also in syntax we also have these
these kind of um
non-non-context-free structures right so
we have
um you know very famously This was um
shown by by Stuart chiber in 1985 right
that in Swiss German there are there
there are these kind of structures where
you can make arbitrarily long links
between uh verbs and their objects which
kind of look look like this and don't
Nest well and this was like the this was
very important like in the world of
syntax to show these like non these like
uh non-context-free uh types of
structures but it's also I think well
accepted overall that that that the
stuff not only occurs and syntax we have
to prove it all the way in 1985 you have
to wait to be able to prove it right but
uh in in language in general and and so
we kind of wanted disentangle the idea
of recursive structure and non-recursive
structure and the effect it has on
language learning
and then lastly we um we also want to
look at the effect of vocabulary
distribution right so
um
the vocabulary in basically like all
languages that have been looked at you
know with of course many caveats but
this is pretty uh
um consistent that that the the human
language vocabulary tends to follow like
a power law distribution right where
some words are very common if I recall
correctly the word the takes up um maybe
like seven percent of of English or
something right and then like there's a
bunch of very very rare words like
zipian or most words that we use most
content words that we use are actually
very rarely used following this the the
this kind of inverse relationship
between Rank and frequency
and so and so to look at these three
hypotheses you know I'm gonna talk talk
about two two parts of the uh the
experiment right on the one hand want to
disentangle the effects of these
recursive structures and these linking
structures Max you know what kind of
structural biases and this transfer
learning approach are useful for human
language Learners and then um on on the
other hand
um yeah we we wanna
uh ask how how this vocabulary
distribution kind of transfers a
structural bias to kind of like Beyond
like the vocabulary that that you can't
exactly transfer how does the idea of
distribution transfer and how can
vocabulary have a structural effect in
general
cool so go on the first part
uh we are we are trying to experiment on
inductive bias right so we want to
change uh we want to kind of swap out
different types of biased Learners and
and then I'll give them pretty limited
linguistic exposure in this case we're
talking like maybe like 100 million
tokens which is by many uh Fields maybe
not pretty limited and I could talk
about the reason we need a lot it's
largely like vocabulary related they
kind of have to learn what what every
word means you have to see every word a
few times this is zip institution does
not help but um yeah
um
yeah and and and and and then we we want
to end up in language learning and and
and and uh see how different types of
structure work as that first question
mark
uh so uh following kind of the format of
the first slides right we take an
untrained gpt2 model these are gpt2
small models
um so we could train them like kind of
fast or it takes like two days or
something on a pretty good GPU
um and and we train on a symbolic
language right so so so so so some kind
of language where where we've taken some
you know setup tokens and made them
follow some structure and then uh we and
so then after this training we can we
create a structurally biased learner
right we we check out the vocabulary
right because because these tokens like
these parentheses tokens or whatever
they are uh in the symbolic language
they're not going to mean anything in
English and uh we and when we fine-tuned
on around 100 million tokens of
Wikipedia and we ask how fast you know
or or how well if we cut it off and you
know at a certain amount of tokens Can
this structurally biased learner learn
language and then to make sure that our
results aren't some effect of of English
right or some we're not saying something
about English structure specifically or
if we are then we then then we know that
we are we test in in uh the the language
the Wikipedia so three languages we do
um English Japanese and Basque so these
are pretty like different languages like
along many accents
um
like say something about Basque typology
so that we have oh it's
um yeah so there's like specific reason
to choose these three languages as
opposed to like any three languages that
are like pretty unrelated bask is just
very interesting and that yeah it's like
it's linguistic isolate so it's like not
really related 20 European language and
it has like interesting ways of doing
argument structure right so like the
ways in which like arguments of the
verbs like whether they be subject or
object are done is kind of is very
different from like most of the
languages in Europe and also like
Japanese has like
um different you know the ways that
things are ordered are different than
the way that like case has a role right
so like again marking the roles of nouns
uh is is yeah is very different from
English but just in many ways they're
just like there's just three uh
typologically very different languages
that are like happened to have because
I've done some work on basketball I just
happen to have like a data set already
but yeah
actually yeah I was going to say yeah
the other 200 and baskets 50 million
yeah but
yeah and it's not for these yeah and
clearly the English Wikipedia is a lot
more than 100 million tokens but yeah I
mean back is very active uh and like uh
ideological like language community and
those languages get pretty big
wikipedias
yeah just to clarify it token means a
word in this context yeah token means a
word it's like a bit
um yeah it's a bit complicated because
turkey doesn't exactly mean a word it
means like um it means a word if it's a
small word and maybe like a part of the
word if it's a very big word is like one
way to just think about it and the main
idea is that if you have a machine
learning tokenizer and it um you know
one way that if you have a bunch of text
and like a machine learning model you
want to feed it in the machine learning
model has to map every like word to a
number and one way you could do this is
like take all the common ones and say
okay all the uncommon ones are just
gonna work with some like unknown token
and then like that's how we're gonna
feed it in another thing you could do is
saying is that you have some like
smarter model that's like well if I
don't know word I'm going to split it
into like the largest chunks of things
that I do kind of know like you know
maybe like prefixes and stuff and then
every word kind of gets a random
presentation so yeah that's a common
word it's a word it's an uncommon and
long word it's probably going to be set
up
thank you
uh yeah so this is our methodology and
then to go into the languages that we
use right so these symbolic pre-training
languages to kind of disentangle and
represent our hypotheses firstly we have
a nesting parenthesis language so so so
this is a language you know where we
have a vocabulary maybe like you know
250 open tokens 250 closed tokens and
then we open and close them in ways
where where they nest well right so it's
like a classic like kind of intro to CS
problem to like build uh a program that
like does this
um I did it now in my PhD uh yeah but
it's um
yeah you know and classically you know
maybe if you were to write this on your
computer right on with your keyboard you
would use like the the the three
brackets that you have right like the
curly the round and the square but you
could just make an arbitrary number of
tokens call them open tokens and then
match and close tokens and we see
because that like this kind of language
has constituency structure right so like
if you pick any one of these like s's in
the subtree and kind of see what what it
encompasses and encompasses another kind
of like well formed string of this type
right and and so it kind of embodies
this like constituency uh idea uh of
recursion
uh the next uh creature nice that we try
you might be surprised uh given the fact
that I mentioned nesting and Crossing in
the introduction right is crossing
dependencies this is it's a very similar
set it's a very similar vocabulary of
open and closed tokens but we just do
not have this well nesting parameter in
them right and so the tokens they have
to match but they don't have to nest and
so seeing this you might ask well is
there like any structure or do you just
like throw some on and then throw some
on you know and they like have to match
somehow and there is some structure
because we uh because we control the
distribution between not matching pairs
right so in order to control these two
types of data between them we uh we can
take the empirical distribution of how
far away matching pairs tend to be in
the other language and then sample from
that to create these uh to create this
language right so when we open a pair
within like sample how far away it's
close closing uh items gonna be and
close it there but but
um but yeah but there's no constituency
structure all you really have is this
kind of structure coming from the fact
that there are ripe times for things to
to close right and so it causes this
like
idea of like expecting certain kinds of
connections to appear
target language what
sorry it's it's it's it's it's just like
oh it's the same yeah yeah sorry I I
didn't clarify that yeah so we get the
dependencies from this just so they're
just so if we see any difference it's
not because like one has dependency
lengths more linked to the target
language or something they're like the
same dependency lengths but just uh
different ideas around constituency and
recursion
and then we also want to have two
controls firstly which one has like a
random language right so language which
is um just like random numbers you have
like maybe the same vocabulary 500
tokens but you just sample from it
totally different structure we have
another language of um which is regular
right so so so it's uh much simpler to
produce uh than the uh than the
um other language actually I think it's
sub regular then then like nesting
parentheses and this is you know it's
very similar to the random language you
just sample uh you know KK words and
then you just repeat them and then you
sample keywords again then you repeat
them so there's some very minimal like
very simple structure but
um it's kind of In This Very finite and
not very complicated way and we want to
kind of control this see if what kind of
structure has an effect yeah
um yeah while we're on the topic of the
controls uh a few a year or two ago
there was this paper that showed that if
you pre-trained a language model on
emergent communication then it you know
if you fine-tune it later on the natural
language task it performs sometimes as
well as pre-training it on natural
language
if you don't know what emergent
communication is like very briefly it's
you let like it's a synthetic language
generated by AI agents and come to
Roberto's talk tomorrow and you know
everything about it but um
my takeaway from or I was struggling to
understand what that experiment meant
originally and then someone told me
um I forgot who uh
basically oh it doesn't even matter what
language he pre-train your Transformer
on all you're doing is like switching
from Transformer to Transformer with
biases that are really good for learning
any kind of
well something something more
complicated than simple repetition but
it doesn't have to be like the domain
doesn't have to be the same domain or
something like that
um I guess
where do you think this falls into all
of your controls
um I I feel like it would be somewhere
in the middle but
yeah so I think that that would be
somewhere at least like how it would be
somewhere like along with like the the
music experiment and that you know
you're giving it something which is
clearly or like I mean I guess like if
they were trying to say something about
the starting data right then but like
emerging communication like depending on
the setup it's probably like kind of
this complex structured like thing
that's happening and so it's interesting
to see this kind of transfer both in
terms of thinking about transfer
learning and in terms of of thinking
about like what kind of structures could
be shared but I think in terms of like
the experimental setup here it's hard to
you know there's not a specific
hypothesis that you have about where
it's about what kind of uh data you're
you're starting from or what kind of
structures you're starting from similar
with music right so there's a lot of
complexity and a lot of like you know
and a lot of constituency and a lot of
microstructure and a lot of but it's
unclear you know there's not one one
thing that you're testing so I'm not
sure how it would fit control I think it
would be kind of like an interesting
other thing to like see along with
everything
yeah maybe you're going to get to this
but
tell me if this is where you're going
with this so if I for example pre-train
with something with nesting dependencies
then
uh if I have a language that has nest
independencies
by pre-trained with nesting dependencies
I should see that fine tuning goes
faster on the language Network domestic
dependency set it by featuring on
something without the best Independence
is that is that where you're headed with
this yeah I mean I think this is like
the kind of analysis about like human
language that we'd want to make so like
understanding like
um what exactly are the structures that
that make human language what it is and
which one of them are like kind of
salient to this like in vitro like kind
of artificial learner you know it's
really hard to make
um comments about language Learners
right using machine learning models but
uh
I think that
um yeah that that and sometimes we're
trying to analyze English like
understand like not does it have less
independencies right because there's
many ways to look at English and most of
them involve uh you know thinking of
some some sort of nesting but like what
kinds of structures form form a good
bias for you know for starting off and
learning English from from there and
yeah and hopefully it kind of creates
some to do some hypothesis generation
about uh the kind of structures
significant like for uh someone trying
to learn English from the data which is
so carbon like large like theoretical
one yeah I guess maybe like the question
was this I thought you were going to
make sure yes success
um here I have a language which we know
has some property like nesting problems
so I'm going to pre-train on data which
has National parentheses and then um as
a control Tree pre-training on something
without it yeah see if I get to the same
level of perplexity or whatever in fewer
steps if I had nesting parentheses in my
free trade yeah and then I thought where
you were gonna go maybe I'm stealing
your thunder I don't know is now I could
say take dolphin language yes and I
could tokenize it
and I could pre-train my uh my my model
on nesting parentheses and I could treat
pre-train it or not and then I could see
if it gets to you know if it takes a
million less steps to get there when I
start with nesting parentheses then I
might that might be an indication that
Dolphins success if that is this your
this is not like the contract at the top
we'll take but I will say like I I think
this is like the idea of using this kind
of uh pre-training and fine-tuning as as
the test bed you know I think it's uh it
is very relevant to looking at like
other types of communication and another
type of structure and trying to
understand and exactly the way you said
like if it takes a million less steps to
to to language models some form of
communication with a pre-trained on
nesting uh then when I preach it on
random then like that that that
indicates that this kind of recursive
structure is significant in like dolphin
language or anything in this case I
think the the focus of these experiments
like start uh
um as they are now to kind of understand
what's even going on with English itself
right yeah and so and so and so we're
we're comparing essentially like the
nesting and The Crossing dependencies
for English to kind of get some insights
from that but I do think that like this
idea of using of using this transfer
learning test bit as a way of
understanding the significant structures
in different uh languages and uh and
between human and non-human
communication as well is yeah like the
the cool end point of this thing that I
hope yeah might be convincing to send
here who could do it
yeah
did that make sense
cool yeah so now on to the results of
our pre-trained then fine-tune Paradigm
uh uh taking the nesting dependencies we
see that nesting structure actually
helps learning I'm not trying to mention
this with the music stuff but not yeah I
think I meant to but I didn't the y-axis
is perplexity which is a measure used
very widely in uh in in knowledge
processing and and lower in this case is
better right it's uh roughly a measure
of like when you're going to go generate
the next word how confused are you
between how many words are you confused
so if you have a lot that you're
confused between that's bad and if you
have a few that's good anyway and so
over here we have our Baseline right
this is a random uh case where there's
just no structure right and that's
pretty bad uh you can still get
somewhere right like in a perplexity of
like 11 like 16 or whatever this is is
like not it's bad but it's not you know
you're still training on language right
then
um over here we have our Baseline on the
other side kind of like a top line which
is what if we take just gpd2 like the
one that was released and we just like
um throughout its vocabulary so it has
like relearned the vocabulary as if like
the structure of English is separated
from the vocabulary but
um yeah the structure that we give it
here is kind of the um the ground truth
like complex structure or whatever of of
English we're going to see that our top
line is not like fully a Top Line some
some things do sometimes fall below it
uh meaning better than it uh and I think
this has to do with vocabulary things
yeah I'd love to hear thoughts on this
but I think it has to to do with like
yeah kind of re relearning from a point
where you're like expecting this like
super wide set of things to happen in
the vector Space versus when you have
like a very narrow kind of small
vocabulary that you've been pre-trained
on it's kind of easier yeah anyway but
the nesting parentheses are is much
better than than our than our Baseline
and like on par with our Top Line yeah
I would imagine some inductive bias test
structure but this incombatable with
human languages yeah that's the that's a
kind of the repetition
kind of has that I think it's hard to
find structure that it is incompatible
with human language right if you're like
very like you know if you're like a very
ideological linguist you would say well
there's some structure which is
extremely basic to human language and
everything else kind of happens to fall
out because of random things but like I
think that there are I I don't know this
is why I had the the repetition thing
where it's like okay clearly this is
like mildly structured but it's not
related human language I think there's
like a kind of just like
every you know word we say just kind of
like fans out and all these like
relationships have influence there's so
many other words that it's like hard to
say that okay here's like a complex
structured thing but it's just like it's
it's nothing like language right I think
that the way to say that has to be kind
of theoretical and ideological and I
think there are a lot of linguists who
say like nesting or bus you know like
everything else is just like kind of
happens to be there but I think it's
hard to say that's like a practical
Viewpoint and more from like a what is
the basic structure the language organ
or something yeah
so the random model here is pre-trained
on the radar yeah and what happens if
you just train them it's like pretty
good it's like right and this is like
kind of the the way that we would it's
like much better than the random and
like oh so so pre-training on the random
data actually makes you worse yeah yeah
and I think
thing behind that is that like
Transformer models they come actually
with this like structural inductive bias
of like Decades of kind of like trying
many things and seeing which one works
for language and so they do actually
have much like the human learner they
actually have this like unknown
inductive bias and so if we're trying to
like separate out the effects of
different inductive biases it's not
super useful to to look at this yeah in
general like nothing that we do is like
just drastically better than than just
training training from scratch like from
like a practical perspective it's like
often like you know maybe significantly
better but yeah that's and is that I
mean so when you say you're throwing out
the word embeddings and you're throwing
out the vocabulary yeah like when you
are you remapping the tokens that you
train before or you're just sticking
like a random
or embedding Matrix back into the model
that was pre-trained and like what's the
distance um we're sampling from the old
word embedding or something Rose from
the old word embedding Matrix this is
like sorry this is all very practical
machine learning stuff but uh yeah and
that's because like it's this has just
been shown in like yeah we had like
transfer papers I had one like a year or
two that was like just better to do this
because you think it's like talking in
like the vector Subspace that like makes
sense for the modeling so yeah but you
throw that there's no meaning to it
essentially yeah you don't throw it out
and then you just okay
cool yeah and so uh
yeah uh looking at the uh yeah and we do
this multilingually we we get similar
results right similar relative results
the go-axis is just very different which
is hard to get any of the models and
backs to be that good I think maybe like
the the train test difference was just
like
bigger or or something but we see that
that like the relative
um
performances uh replicate uh from
English to Japanese and Basque and then
coming back to to your question about
um you know what what if we want just
kind of a simpler you know a something
that is structured but it isn't like
very linguistic in any way
um so we're asking does any structure
help or does this like repetition also
help and we see that you know it's
actually the complexity of the nesting
right kind of like this like context
freeness it is necessary I think it is
pretty notable also that there is this
big difference right between Rand random
and just like um and just like random
with repetition right so like simple
structure does like kind of serve as a
better inductive bias but doesn't even
get us like anywhere near this kind of
like acceptable perplexity range that uh
we get
um with with with this iconic Street
nesting this is a also Trend transfers
to the other language like same shape of
graphs uh for Japanese and for
basketball yeah for these questions so
in this chart where the model without
the pre-training uh B
well rapper training goes yeah it goes
like somewhere like here or something
right it's like some somewhere where
it's yeah where it's like it's pretty
good right it's like yeah it's pretty
what is it's good to start from what is
the intuition I mean you start with
random weights right so I would expect
you know even if you train a random uh
input
your weights are gonna be kind of random
at the end
or so I guess like random weights in
like a very kind of like useful
architecture doesn't mean like a random
inductive bias right so so by
pre-pre-training we're kind of like
imbuing the model with an inductive bias
and um and having a random right so so
so so like what we're kind of arguing is
that by pre pre-training or kind of
giving a model the the tendency to work
with these kinds of structures when the
model's on trains we don't know what
structured attempts to work with like we
assume they're useful right because
we've ended up using Transformers after
you know whatever like five Decades of
people trying to get connections models
to work so it's probably a good idea
um and and so I think an untrained
Transformer it's like kind of I don't
think it's like a blank slate learner
and uh Marco Baroni has a great paper on
this right it's kind of like it's like
it's a learner it's maybe it's not like
as language like laser focus is like a
human e-learner right where like every
human learns learns language no problem
in any uh conditions right but it's
still somehow like been you know like
the architecture is still somehow
focused towards the language and so
think about the fact that we can ruin it
by pre-training on random kind of gives
credence this idea that pre-training can
serve as like conductive bias in viewing
in a way
uh yeah
advice or is it just because it just
results
yeah I think it's hard to
separate those two like I think like
some way to look at any machine learning
problems like oh it's all like
optimization right like even like
pre-training and then fine-tuning on
some tasks right like even like Bert or
something might just be like a good
initially right so so I think it's hard
separated I think it definitely makes a
poor initialization like if you want to
you know like I would you know like at
least for like this talk I would argue
that it's like because it's kind of the
furniture Edition comes from the fact
that you're kind of like biasing it
towards like structures that are or like
you know towards like not having any
structural bias and not expecting kind
of anything interesting to happen right
but yeah
because then it's been kind of override
oh like a good Escape problem
all four initiative yeah yeah so I think
one of the reason that we do kind of
like kind of limited to pre-training is
because you could always just like
Escape before any association with
enough data right like if it's however
you initialize gpt4 it kind of wouldn't
matter as much right but yeah um there's
not a difference in learning rate I
don't think yeah I think we use like the
standard like 52
things I think you know some hyper
parameter search would have been like
very interesting but also like it's hard
to know you know it's a film if you're
just not training well enough but these
results are pretty consistent with what
yeah
seems to be the case in language and so
we kind of took them yeah thank you yeah
sorry continuing at this point that the
particular mentioned so it's probably
not correct to completely call it an
inductive bias I would say that
inductive bias would be if you change
the model itself so
myself had a paper if they clear whether
they showed that you can do some
pre-structure in the Transformer or
maybe editor you can use uh
that will probably be
more of an indexifiers rather than
pre-tracing because because pre-training
again it's just an initial point and you
might get stuck somewhere around it so
good service but you probably don't have
any guarantee whatsoever that's the case
yeah yeah I think it's it's hard to like
contemporates exactly what like
conductive bias mean by the kind of like
think of the interest for this word
comes from kind of like uh you know like
language faculty ideas right which are
like well the human brain has some kind
of a thing that makes you know the human
mind can like understand uh can like
learn language because of some kind of
thing you know like well this is like
Universal grammar like not you know like
it's and so and so kind of giving the
structure to say okay what if your thing
is that you know how to do this kind of
structural relationships right then um
how does that work so I think it is one
way of you know in viewing uh so
everything has to be structural and then
like architectural sense I I I do also
you know yeah I think the machine
learning like the fact that like we're
basing so much on like stochastic
reading set is you know is it's a weird
thing you know they might working in my
you know or sometimes it might just be
bad and you have like search around but
I think in general we do have like
extremely powerful like language
Learners like in our hands which was
like just not the case for any kind of
language learning experiments
um in the same way until recently of
those do happen to be just like creative
descent based models so this is the way
to you know use them through this kind
of like hypothesis generation right none
of this is like some kind of proof about
Universal grammar
yeah uh yeah oh no I won't go ahead I
can ask you later are you sure yeah yeah
okay okay yeah cool yeah and this is
again a multilingual effect we see the
same stuff and then oh we're gonna go
back to kind of like our our uh other
thing that we're trying to disentangle
from the nesting parentheses right so so
uh trying to understand how how do these
Crossing dependencies uh act as as this
inductive uh bias as a starting point
um we see that that that these Crossings
without nesting they're actually like
better right they're they're they're
better than
um than
nesting right even though they don't
have any constituent structure kind of
like this like long this like kind of
wide ranging kind of linking idea this
kind of uh being ready for things to
happen I guess is how I think of like
kind of language modeling this thing is
a good uh inductive bias uh and this
again rev replicates to our um to our
other two two languages
and
and so I guess the the conclusion that I
would draw from this so like the kinds
of structures that make language
language right they're multifaceted
right it's a you know like theoretically
me we we might want to focus on some for
like the purpose like theoretical
Linguistics but you know structural
transfer lets us explore the the
multifaceted ways that like language can
be structured or like any data that
we're interested in can be structured
and think of language as this learnable
system that can be learned from from
different starting points kind of in
independent from you know what we think
is important theoretically
and then uh one last experiment to to to
to to test out these um effects is uh
mixing the nesting and the crossing
parentheses right so what if we have
these nesting parentheses and we just
add maybe like one percent of tokens are
just like don't go along with the
constituency structure they just like
sample the the uh from from the
dependency distribution just say get
placed you know roguely or ten percent
um and uh and what and what we see in
this case that slightly breaking
consistency structure it still makes
better language Learners right so uh
yeah uh and you can see it's it gets
created right from like 100 nesting
right to to one percent Crossing to 10
Crossing being like almost equivalent to
The Crossing dependencies
um yeah so this idea of like having the
ability to have multifaceted
relationships between words that aren't
um that aren't
um
necessarily kind of governed by by one
type of uh kind of uh constituency
relation seemed to be very helpful as a
starting point
uh
yeah that was the one and the ten being
highlighted and uh yeah this this also
wrote Lucas for other languages uh yeah
do you have a question
you just put a random token there it's
the same like it's the same vocabulary
that you use but you know as you've been
like I have my stack and I'm working
like opening closing open and closing
with my stack thing like oh it's like
you know I sampled my one percent chance
so I'm just gonna put someone in there
and then like close them later like
whenever they want to be closed from
there like
you know according to the dependency
length distribution and then like just
continue going with my stack
does that make sense like it's all it
looks it looks it looks like this
generally
with
one percent
probably that you're not just putting a
random token there rather you are just
putting a matching pair of tokens I mean
at every Point you're putting a random
token I mean you're like picking some
kind of open forecast right like you
have this large vocabulary that you're
picking but if you're closing the token
you do it according to like yes yes yes
yeah well in this case you put an open
and a closed token you you sample from
that dependency like distribution so you
sample the distance between them and
then you just kind of place them and
then you just go on as if that hadn't
happened
yeah
and so you just kind of break the
constituent structure it's also
multilingual and so yeah it just goes to
show like the ways in which a complex
structural relationships are important
in language learning and that this kind
of
um multifaceted ideas like multiple
Crossing dependencies uh uh that bring
out this linking uh structure in
language which is like prevalent across
many levels that they're a good starting
point for language learning and um
hopefully what this can show and what
can you know and if there's and
hopefully this can be like helpful for
like other types of modalities as well
beyond human language is like
computational models especially now that
like we have pretty good machine
learning models that we can work with we
can use them as kind of hypothesis
generators right for testing this
linguistic structure
um that yeah and the types of structure
which are significant or present in
different types of
um data
cool yeah uh moving on to vocabulary
this is much shorter but I thought you
know like I think vocabulary is like a
big part from from what I've understood
of non-uh human communication
understanding right I think that it's
important thing to start from right it's
important in linguistics too accept that
we kind of know it when we start right
but it's
um the Lexicon in linguistics uh yeah
like cross-independence
um it's also possible that uh like
learning cursor will dependency was
ordered the learning as the dependencies
so how does the percentages of
data used title like how much
what portion of language actually
requires no understanding that
particular kind of structure because
it's possible
you can draw much of a conclusion like
specifically it's like oh it's ten
percent then you know that's like the
best or something but there's this idea
that like you know having to learn the
kinds of structures which are like
constituency like but like often like
broken or like rarely broken but still
can be broken kind of it's like a better
like kind of structural starting point
for for language yeah I'm not like a
specific 10 percent you've been transfer
20 like linguistic hypothesis as far as
experiments yeah yeah so the next kind
of linguistics right it's very important
right because a good amount of structure
is in the vocabulary right Department
distribution but I'm going to talk about
um you know there's like structure in in
meaning you know and there's only
structure and grammar right like
um uh vocabulary items have things like
being transitive verbs right or you know
there's like constructions right if we
have like the words let alone right it
kind of those like two lexical items you
know this is not like a general right uh
it's it's not a general like syntactic
rule but those two lexical items kind of
means that okay what happened before
right oh I won't do this let alone that
right is that what happened before it's
kind of less extreme than what happens
later and it's kind of placed in the
structural way right and like in so many
ways like the Lexicon kind of holds a
lot of a lot of um a lot of the grammar
that that forms our language and so in
our case you know we throw out the
vocabulary between pre-training and
fine-tuning uh you know because we have
this pre-training vocabulary you know
and what the model sees is like a bunch
of numbers corresponding to a bunch of
parentheses things which are just like
totally useless if then what it wants to
see is a bunch of different numbers
corresponding to a bunch of you know uh
words real words so we we throw it out
and now we we want to test okay even
though we throw it out
um how does having a different
vocabulary distribution can that
influence down Downstream effects
um
uh and what we see is that it does right
so this is across the three languages uh
having a uniform Distribution on the
left the the yellow is is better is
worse than having a zipian distribution
on on on the right recipient being like
this power law uh distribution in the
pre in the pre-training and this does
not necessarily combine with structure
right so if we then take
um uh our parentheses languages and we
and we try having uniform or zip in
between them right so like in in the
leftmost panel that's English right on
the left you know on on the XX we have
like the nesting parenthesis and the
crossing dependencies
um it's not exactly consistent between
languages which way it goes so it seems
that vocabulary distribution doesn't
exactly like override or like work with
structural bias in how we we
pre-pre-train it and
um yeah it's not the role of vocabulary
in transference learning is just an
interesting problem right because
whenever you have a really big
Transformer model sometimes really big
vocabulary embedding Matrix so you kind
of you know you fit you uh you just have
to make each vector be good kind of by
itself and yeah I think it's an
interesting problem to to to think of
um yeah in a practical way right because
without enough data you know it's hard
to see a word often enough to have a
good Vector you know they're like
vocabulary specific presentations
they're like so important right they
have properties like being a verb or
something but it's hard to like have
that well
um and it's also you know and I think
it's also this interesting puzzle right
like our results kind of show that
structural information you know about
the vocabulary can kind of bleed out of
the Matrix into how like attention
weights we're going to tell like the
transformer model works and uh yeah I
think this is all like I don't know
things to cool things like keep in mind
when like working between languages or
between modalities where like there's no
notion of shared vocabulary where you're
not going to get any clues from the
vocabulary
um
yeah
cool so yeah just to conclude uh
transfer learning you know can be this
test Ed for for understanding structure
in language learning right this uh this
idea of like pre predisposing a model to
one kind of structure and then
and then using that to
um
to to understand your like structure of
Interest right whether it be like the
English language or or anything else you
know computational models of cognitive
processes like language you know they
can't prove anything but you know they
they serve as these interesting like
hypothesis generators to work with you
know these interesting ways of uh
of knowing
um
yeah of of kind of testing out different
ideas you know thinking of systems
especially as learnable systems right so
language as just like a learnable system
and uh yeah hopefully I can also
convince at some exciting time that
machine learning opens up new new
avenues uh for exploring questions in
language and Linguistics kind of in ways
that weren't possible before and that
um are are uh are very cool
the question you had before sure yeah
so uh
obviously I the modeling part of it is
is beyond me as the biologist but
um I guess I was just wondering if
something was had some kind of power law
to it whether it was exactly as if or
not where some things are used a lot and
some things are rarely used but it
wasn't recursive like there was no
nesting to it where would
where would you ex like which model
which pre-trained model would you expect
to perform best
so trying to split the difference
between those two aspects yeah I think
that's like the part that we're still
thinking about it seems that actually
like in our setup in our kind of test
bed set up they don't work together so
if you have like zipian especially I've
been having uniform for like random
pre-training and then you know if you
have uh if you have like some some kind
of structure you know it's much better
than than not for uh
for the you know for the for the
pre-preaching as well but you know
having like both recipient and
um and like the nesting parenthesis is
not that different from like the uniform
nesting parenthesis or it wasn't
consistent across our languages so we
didn't see it as like a as like a signal
and so I think it's just good to like
test it all out right like I think it's
a way yeah like as Brian was saying to
like you know if if you take this like
nesting thing and it's like a good
starting point for for something than
like you know then like that's a signal
that that that that these kind of
context restructures are are important
and uh you know but then you you would
also want to try the the recipients it
does this kind of like
parallel transfer uh yeah
transferring does that make it kind of
like a more learnable thing you know so
like maybe if I have parallel Instinct
right and and then I can better learn
learn this communication that I keep
hearing then um
yeah then then that means something
right about like how maybe the
vocabulary maybe something else is
structured kind of in a zipian way yeah
and then you'd also want to try other
hypothesis right like we did the linking
and I think that would be cool right
like to see if nesting doesn't work like
at all but linking works right that says
something about how like specific form
of communications are structured in
different ways
cool thank you
do you think this transfer learning
approach can be used as a model for a
general language learning because I'm
thinking like you know babies sort of
star from a learning very simple
languages a sort of the signal stuff
yeah and then sort of build up from
their more complex structures yeah
um and also I think like language is not
um like for instance completion language
is not fully
um I mean language is doesn't have
constructs that are fully compositional
are more mixed so I'm thinking like more
as a linguistically motivated curriculum
learning could be used to learn language
and do you think this approach can can
help in that yeah I think in some sense
like curriculum learning is yes is it's
like you know a version of transfer
learning right curriculum knows when you
learn kind of some stuff first because
it's like supposedly easier you know in
some way and then and yeah I think like
yeah if you want to move you know like
outside of the domain of okay what kind
of structural biases help and you want
to you know as we try to to to do as use
as you said with like the uh The
Crossing parenthes you know to try to
move towards like what language is so
complicated there's so many things that
could be happening maybe I could just
start with like simple uh you know like
kind of simple languages like kind of
has a lot of the structures but not a
lot of the complexity you know maybe
like that's a good and I think that's
true and I think there's there's a cool
paper
um I think uh Aaron
Miller's student might have been the
first author about like curriculum
learning that came out recently about
how like even like starting from like we
start from like a child directed speech
and then go to simple English Wikipedia
and then go to Wikipedia it's like much
better for training a model than just
going straight to Wikipedia so I think
yeah I think that this stuff is very
interesting the kind of like the
building up of structural complexity and
of like kind of semantic complexity
foreign